you ready lex
yes i'm ready do you guys want to come
in and put the
interfaces on our heads and then i will
proceed to tell you a few jokes
so we uh who have two incredible pieces
of technology
and a machine running ubuntu 2004 in
front of us
what are we doing all right are these
going on our heads they're going on our
heads yeah
and they will place it on our heads for
proper alignment
does this support giant heads because i
kind of have a giant head
is this is just as like an ego
or are you saying physically both
it's a nice massage yes
okay how does it feel moved around
it's okay to move around yeah it feels
oh yeah
[Music]
this feels awesome thank you that feels
good
so this is big head friendly it suits
you well lex
thank you i
feel like i need to uh i feel like when
i wear this i need to sound like sam
harris calm
collected eloquent
i feel smarter actually i don't think
i've ever felt
quite as much like i'm part of the
future as now have you ever
worn a brain interface or had your brain
image
oh never had my brain imaged
the only way i've analyzed my brain is
by
talking to myself and thinking no direct
data
yeah yeah that is it that is definitely
an interface
that has a lot of blind spots it has
some blind spots
yeah psychotherapy that's right
all right are we recording
all right so lex the objective
of this i'm going to
tell you some jokes and your objective
is to not smile
which as a russian you should have
an edge make the motherland proud i
gotcha
okay let's hear the jokes
lex and this is from the colonel crew
we've been working on a device that can
read your mind
and we would love to see your thoughts
is that the joke that's the opening okay
if if i'm if i'm seeing the muscle
activation correctly on your
on your lips you're not going to do well
on this let's see all right here here
comes the first unscrewed here comes the
first one
is this going to break the device is it
resilient
to uh to laughter
lex what goes through a potato's brain
i already failed that's the hilarious
opener okay
what tater thoughts
what kind of fish performs brain surgery
i don't know a neural surgeon
and so we're getting data of everything
that's happening in my brain right now
lifetime yeah we're getting
activation patterns of your entire
cortex
i might try to do better i let it out
all the parts where i left
in photoshop you have a serious face
over me you can recover
all right lex what do scholars eat
when they're hungry i don't know what
academia
nuts
that's pretty good so what we'll do
is so you're wearing
kernel flow which is
an interface built uh using technology
called spectroscopy so it's similar to
what we wear
wearables on the wrist using light so
using lidar as you know
and we're using that to image
it's a functional imaging of brain
activity and so as your neurons fire
electrically and and chemically it
creates
blood oxygenation levels we're measuring
that and so when you'll see in the
reconstructions we do for you
you'll see your activation patterns in
your brain as throughout this entire
time we are wearing it
so in the reaction to the jokes and as
we were sitting here talking
and so it's a we're moving towards a
real-time
feed of your cortical brain activity so
there's a bunch of
things that are in contact with my skull
right now how many of them are there and
so how many of them are
what are they what are the actual
sensors there's 52 modules
and each module has one laser and six
sensors and they're the sensors fire
in about 100 picoseconds and then the
photons
scatter and absorb in your brain and
then a few go in if you come back out a
bunch go in that a few come back out and
we
sense those photons and then we do the
reconstruction for the activity
overall there's about a thousand plus
channels
that are sampling your activity how
difficult is it to make it as
comfortable as it is
because it's surprisingly comfortable i
would not think it would be comfortable
something that's measuring brain
activity i would not think it would be
comfortable
but it is i agree in fact i want to take
this home
yeah yeah that's right so people are
accustomed
to being in big systems like fmri where
there's 120 decibel sounds and you're in
a claustrophobic
encasement or eeg which is just painful
or surgery and so yes i agree that this
is a
convenient option to be able to just put
on your head it measures your brain
activity
in the contextual environment you choose
so if we want to have it during the
podcast if we want to be at home
in a business setting so we it's freedom
to be where
to record your brain activity in the
setting that you choose yeah but sort of
from an engineering perspective
are these uh what is it there's a bunch
of different
modular parts and they're kind of
there's like a rubber band thing
where they they mold to the shape of
your head that's right
so we we built this this version of the
mechanical design
to accommodate most adult heads
but i have a giant head and if it's fine
i feel it fits well actually
so i don't think i have an average head
okay
maybe i feel i feel much better about my
head now maybe i am
i'm more average than i thought okay so
what else is there interesting you could
say what's up while it's on our heads i
can keep this on the whole time this is
kind of awesome
and it's amazing for me as a fan of
ubuntu i use ubuntu mate you guys should
use
that too but it's amazing to have code
running
to the side measuring stuff and
collecting data
i mean that i just i feel like much more
important now
that my data is being recorded like
somebody care
like you know when you you have a good
friend that listens to you
that actually like listens like actually
is listening to you this is what i feel
like
i'm like a much better friend because
it's like accurately listening to me
ubuntu what a cool perspective i hadn't
thought about that
of feeling understood yeah
heard yeah heard deeply
by the mechanical system that is
recording your brain activity
versus the human that you're engaging
with that your mind immediately goes to
that there's this dimensionality and
depth of understanding
yeah of this software system which
you're intimately familiar with
and now you're able to communicate with
this system in ways that you couldn't
before
yeah i feel heard
yeah i mean i guess what's interesting
about this is your intuitions
are spot on most people have intuitions
about brain interfaces that
they've grown up with this idea of
people moving cursors on the screen or
typing or changing the channel or
skipping a song it's
primarily been anchored on control and
i think the more relevant understanding
of brain
interfaces or neural imaging is that
it's a measurement system
and once you have numbers for a given
thing
a seemingly endless number of
possibilities emerge around that of what
to do with those numbers
so before you tell me about the
possibilities this was an incredible
experience
i can keep this on for another two hours
but i'm being
told that uh for a bunch of reasons
just because we probably want to keep
the data small and visualize it nicely
for the final product we want to cut
this off and take this
to take this amazing helmet away from me
so
brian thank you so much for this
experience and let's uh
let's continue without helmetless all
right
you